the story being told by texas police  about their involvement  in trying to stop the shooter in uvalde  texas is increasingly being scrutinized  because quite frankly it has a lot of  holes in it we have now learned that  after engaging  the shooter outside the school  police did  the shooter went in  and spent 40 to 60 minutes shooting up a  classroom what exactly were police doing  during that time there are some early  reports we're doing our best to wait  until we know definitively but it is not  looking particularly good and it is  raising more questions about whether a  so-called good guy with a gun  really is the solution